[Music]
so yeah here we are downstairs in the
boat and you see it's quite cozy and
very simple but yeah there's six bunks
on each side going along here and if we
ever tack or jibe then we'll have to
swap sides so we get woken up go on deck
do the maneuver and then sleep the other
side you share a bunk with the person
who's on the opposite watch to you you
want to make sure they like you and that
they give you you know a nice psyche
it's time to wake up now rather than the
like trying to scare you kind of wake up
there's four watches and we spend four
hours on deck and those four watches
overlap by by two hours so you spent
four hours upstairs racing about hard
making sure the boat thing fast then you
come down and you have your four hours
off which if you're looking is four
hours off our cooking facilities are
pretty limited this is our you know
glorious kitchen we've got two paddles
to boil water with some little camping
gases underneath them we have a fresh
water tap and we've a saltwater tap so
you don't want to make you dinner with
sort of will move food from the main
food bags into the daily food bag and
inside us is a it's not the most
exciting thing but when you're hungry
it's a it seems pretty good but like I
know tomorrow for dinner I am going to
be getting a chicken tikka curry
freeze-dried in boiled water you put it
in you mix this and then leave it for 10
minutes to rehydrate and and then you
get to eat us and it's a it's alright so
yeah here we are at the front of the
boat and usually this space essentially
is used for storing kit if it's light
airs we'll have all the kit forward here
at the front and and in that case as
well we won't be sleeping the bunks
anymore we'll be sleeping on the floor
on bags on sales where we have down here
so this is a luxurious bathroom lots of
privacy as you can see
that's enough of that this is a our knob
station and here's Brian Thompson our
our awesome navigator who's gonna point
us in the right direction because that's
pretty much the most important job on
the boat
you